- This episode of Real Law Review
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer for free
for two months by clicking
the link in the description.
Paul Manafort lied so
much that the Mueller team
is ripping up his plea agreement.
This is very unusual and
this has huge implications
for the entire Trump legal defense team.
Let's think like a lawyer.
(whimsical music)
On today's Real Law Review
I wanna talk about all
the implications that come
as a result of Paul
Manafort breaking the terms
of his plea agreement with
the Mueller legal team
including one, why
Manafort is going to jail
for a long time; two, how he has exposed
all of his communications
with President Trump
and the rest of the Trump team,
including those protected by
attorney-client privilege;
and three, why even a pardon
won't save Paul Manafort.
This has huge implications for everyone
including the President.
You may recall that Paul
Manafort was indicted
in two separate jurisdictions.
He was the defendant in one
particular criminal case
on the Eastern District of
Virginia, that's federal court,
as well as the District of D.C.,
which again is another federal district.
The Eastern District of Virginia,
because of its proximity to D.C.
Handles a lot of very
high profile federal cases
and this is no exception to that.
The Virginia case went to trial first.
Paul Manafort was convicted
on most of the crimes alleged
in the Eastern District of Virginia case,
and the jury hung on
a few of those claims,
meaning they weren't able to
come to a unanimous decision
on those particular claims.
As a result of losing
so many of the claims
in the Virginia case,
enough to put him away
for the rest of his life,
Manafort and his legal team
decided to plead out in D.C.,
meaning he took a plea agreement
where he got a reduced
sentence in exchange
for him cooperating with the
ongoing Mueller investigation.
Not surprisingly, the plea agreement
that Mueller and Manafort entered into
requires that Manafort cooperate entirely
not only into the actual crimes
that he was indicted and convicted of
but also for any investigations
that Mueller wants his cooperation with
and that Manafort might
have some information
that would help out.
Manafort pleaded pursuant to an agreement
that required his fully,
truthfully, completely,
and forthrightly cooperating
with the government.
According to the sentencing memo
that the Mueller team just filed,
the plea agreement provides
that if the defendant,
Manafort, fails to fulfill completely
each and every one of his obligations
under the plea agreement or quote,
"engages in any criminal
activity prior to sentencing,"
the defendant, Manafort, will
be in breach of the agreement.
And, of course, a breach
relieves the government
of any obligations
under the plea agreement
including its agreement to a reduction
of the sentencing
guidelines for acceptance
and responsibility but leaves intact
all of the obligations of the defendant
as well as his guilty pleas.
Which means that if Manafort
violated the plea agreement
he is not entitled to any
reduction of any of the crimes
that he was convicted of an
in fact he cannot withdraw
his guilty plea as a result.
No matter what, Manafort
is going to be stuck
with his admission of guilt
with no reduction in sentence.
In the status report that the
Mueller team recently filed
both in D.C. and Virginia,
according to Mueller,
after signing the plea agreement,
Manafort committed federal crimes by lying
to the Federal Bureau of Investigation
and the Special Counsel's Office
on a variety of subject matters
which constitute breaches
of the agreement.
The government will file a
detailed sentencing submission
to the probation department
and the Court in advance of
the sentencing that sets forth
the nature of the
defendant's crimes and lies
including those after signing
the plea agreement herein.
This is a bombshell filing
by the Mueller team.
It is very rare for these
kinds of plea agreements
to blow up and what the
Mueller team has hinted at here
is that Manafort not only just lied once
and failed to communicate
but lied on a variety
of different subjects.
So what are the consequences
of this plea agreement blowing up?
Well for one the Mueller team
won't be able to use Paul
Manafort as a cooperating witness.
They won't be able to rely
on his testimony at trial.
They won't get him to waive
his 5th Amendment rights
against self incrimination
and of course Paul
Manafort is going to jail
for a very, very long time.
The reason you enter into
one of these plea agreements
is to get a reduction in your sentence.
You make it easier for the
government to prove their case,
you admit your guilt, and in exchange
the government gives you a letter
saying that you should get
a reduction in sentence.
A judge has some leeway in what sentence
is actually handed down.
There are federal guidelines,
federal sentencing guidelines
that provide a certain range
and the judge is allowed to
choose from within that range
and the government states
that because you cooperated
with their investigation
you should get a
reduction in your sentence
at the low end of the
sentencing guideline range.
Of course, when you back out
of a plea agreement like this
the government no longer needs
to say nice things about you
and no longer needs to argue
that you should get a
reduction in your sentence
and in fact they will
do exactly the opposite.
Instead, the government will argue
that because of your bad conduct
you should get an
enhancement in your sentence.
You should be at the high end of the range
or if you engaged in new crimes,
then you can be sentenced
to additional time
that was not reflected in
your original guilty plea.
So Paul Manafort is in a world of hurt.
Manafort's breach of the plea agreement
and lies to federal prosecutors
may be related to a report coming out
of the UK's Guardian Newspaper
which reports that Paul
Manafort met extensively
with Julian Assange of WikiLeaks
before the 2016 election.
If that is proved to be true,
that could have huge implications
for the conspiracy and
collusion investigation
that's going on.
On top of that, there
is yet another bombshell
that reports that while
Manafort was acting
as a cooperating witness
with the Mueller team,
both Manafort and his attorneys
were passing secret
information to President Trump
and the other Trump campaign defendants.
This is a huge bombshell.
Generally speaking, if
you talk to your lawyer,
those communications are protected
by attorney-client
privilege, no surprise there.
If you talk to a third party
who is not your attorney,
the general rule is
there is no attorney-client
privilege whatsoever.
Those communications are not privileged
and they are discoverable.
However, when you have multiple
defendants on one side,
often they share what's
called a common interest.
Which means that what's
good for one defendant
is also good for the other
defendants and as a result
it's very favorable to be
able to share information
among different defendants
and their lawyers.
And you wouldn't wanna
share that information
if it breached attorney-client privilege
and those communications were exposed.
So the court recognizes
what's called a common interest doctrine,
which allows those defendants
to communicate back and forth.
To do that you have to sign
what's called a Joint Defense Agreement
which basically just
codifies that relationship
and allows communications
to go back and forth.
However, the wrinkle comes
when one of those
defendants no longer shares
a common interest with
the other defendants.
When one of those defendants
enters into a plea agreement
that defendant's interests
are no longer aligned
with the other defendants.
The other defendants
presumably wanna fight the case
and wanna be proven innocent
whereas the defendant who has pled guilty
wants a reduction in sentence
and wants to make the prosecution's case
as easy as possible.
So in that circumstance, those defendants
are no longer in the same common interest.
So what generally happens
is that when one defendant pleads out
they remove themselves from
the Joint Defense Agreement
so that their communications
are not exposed
and discoverable and the other
defendants' communications
are no longer exposed and discoverable.
But apparently that did not happen here,
even after Manafort entered
into his plea agreement,
was a cooperating witness
with the Mueller team,
and had pled guilty to the crimes alleged
in the District of Columbia case,
he was still part of the
Joint Defense Agreement
with the rest of the Trump team.
That means that the communications
that any of the Trump lawyers
and Trump defendants had
with Manafort or his attorneys,
while under the guise of
this Joint Defense Agreement
are no longer protected.
If those communications
and that work product
is no longer protected by
the Joint Defense Agreement
and no longer protected by
the attorney-client privilege
then they are discoverable.
If I was one of Mueller's investigators
I would simply send a written request over
to not only Paul Manafort's lawyers
but to all of the Trump defendant lawyers
demanding that they turn
over any communications
and any work product that
was shared amongst themselves
while Paul Manafort was
a cooperating witness.
Because Paul Manafort doesn't
have the same interest
as the rest of the defendants
and potential defendants
in this investigation, the
Common Interest doctrine
doesn't apply and the
Joint Defense Agreement
can't protect all of their communications
and their work product.
Not only does this have
malpractice written all over it
if the clients weren't
apprised of the fact
that they could be subject
to these disclosures
as a result of these
secret communications,
but on top of that
I don't think that Paul Manafort's lawyers
are really going to be able to practice
in federal court anymore
because no prosecutor
would ever trust them
to keep the terms of a
plea agreement secret.
And if you can't negotiate
with the government
then your value as a federal
criminal defense lawyer
is really going to plummet.
So why would someone do this?
Well, a lot of people are speculating
that Paul Manafort is angling
for a Presidential pardon
and that may be true.
There are two schools of thought here.
The first is that Paul Manafort
thinks he is the smartest guy in the room
and he can beat the federal prosecutors.
It's not uncommon
for criminals to think that
they are smarter than they are
and smarter than the prosecutors
who are going to put them in jail,
especially when it comes
to white collar criminals
like Paul Manafort who
are used to getting away
with skirting the law
and beating regulators.
So it may be
that Manafort just thinks
he can get away with it.
He lied his way into the situation
and he can lie his way out
of the situation, we'll see.
The second school of thought on this
is that Manafort is angling
for a Presidential pardon.
If he works with Mueller he
can get a reduction in sentence
but the theory is that if he
works with President Trump
who can pardon him, he
can avoid jail altogether.
That could be, but there
are some problems with that
because remember Manafort has been charged
in both Virginia and D.C.
and there have been credible reports
that Manafort is guilty
of all kinds of crimes
in New York as well.
And the problem for Manafort
is that a lot of the same conduct
for which he has already pled guilty
could give rise to state-level charges.
Specifically in the case
of Virginia and New York,
he could be convicted of tax fraud.
And remember, a Presidential pardon
can only pardon federal crimes.
Which would still leave
Manafort on the hook
for any state law crimes.
On top of that
the Mueller team is probably
going to retry Manafort
on all of the crimes for which
the jury hung in Virginia
and they will argue for an
enhancement of sentencing
for the crimes that Manafort
has already pled guilty.
In the latest status report,
the Mueller team has promised
to lay out all of
Manafort's lies and failures
to cooperate in great detail.
It's going to be fascinating
to read that document.
We don't have those details right now
but they're gonna argue
for a sentence enhancement.
But the bottom line is that Paul Manafort
is going to spend a long
time in either federal
or state prison.
Of course, he could put
that time to good use
by learning a new skill
like learning how to draw.
He could take classes on how
to draw comic book characters
by Robert Marzullo on Skillshare.
In fact, he could learn
how to draw a whole comic
about a guy named Super Paul who resides
in the Manafortress.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000 classes on everything
like design, technology,
business, you name it.
And the first 500 Legal Eagles
to click on the link below
will get two free months of Skillshare,
just by clicking the link.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must-know topics so you
can improve your skills
and learn new things, just
like Paul Manafort will
when he goes to prison.
(bars clunk)
So click on the link and
start learning today.
And until next time,
I'll see you in court.